this video is brought to you by
brilliant
hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
artificial intelligence is generally
good at pattern recognition and
prediction but what about creativity in
previous episodes we've seen the first
signs of creativity or at least the
mimicking of creativity
we saw ai research generating fashion
models or generating faces that don't
exist from scratch and creating living
portraits which interestingly since then
has now made it into a tiktok filter
but towards the end of that episode we
touched on ai creating music
at the time many people were surprised
that things like this were possible but
today we're going to dive deeper
being a musician and a producer myself
this was particularly interesting to me
but i think what you're about to see and
hear will be interesting to most people
it brings up a fascinating philosophical
question about human nature
is it even possible for a machine to
produce original music what's the
closest that we've gotten today and what
is creativity anyway in this episode
i'll attempt to answer these questions
let's take a look
[Music]
to better understand the ai generated
music later in the episode we should
first look at how music is created by
humans
when i think about music creation it
usually comes in two main forms playing
live instruments and tracking them in
software or using digital instruments
and arranging them also in software
[Music]
at the genesis of either method a song
usually begins with a seed in my
experience that seed can be anything
from playing a guitar riff a bass line
some synth chords
or even a vocal sample
[Music]
when i listen to the seed i begin to
hear what comes next to my head and then
i figure out how to get what's in my
head into the computer and then layer it
on top and then i repeat the process
until something begins to take shape
this is just how i imagine my music
creation process to be logically it may
be different for others here's an
example
so here i'm just jamming out some
different parts and triggering different
loops that i've made
so i started off with a synth line
and then i hear a bass line in my head
so i play that bass line in
[Music]
interestingly for the vocals in this i
used ai to isolate the vocal sample from
a 1975 song
[Music]
it was just a simple website that
allowed me to do this
next i just add some drums that i think
would go with that
[Music]
then i just keep building part by part
after jamming out the tune to work out
all the parts i start putting it into a
structure
and i just keep repeating the process
and adding more parts that i hear in my
head and then playing them into the
computer
and the end result is convincing if you
add some film footage on top you can get
something that has a pretty emotional
effect
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
the only inputs are from what i'm
hearing that is what i've already played
and the output is from my imagination
given that input
[Music]
perhaps in my subconscious i have heard
these melodies somewhere else but i'm
really not aware of it in this case
[Music]
[Applause]
so let's compare this to ai
artificial intelligence on the other
hand listens to many examples learns
what the patterns are and then creates
something quote unquote new they don't
need to consistently receive input from
a programmer
really it builds on patterns it's
learned from previous experience
say for example a user can input two or
more types of melodies and then use
machine learning to combine them in a
new way could we say that it's somewhat
similar to what other musicians do we'll
explore the answer to this at the end of
the episode
for now let's take a look at the state
of the art in ai creating music
so currently machines can make music in
two main ways
either manipulating midi data or raw
audio synthesis
we'll check out the best examples of
both
google's magenta is a music writing ai
that learns from previous melodies drum
patterns and other sounds to create new
ones in 2021 a toronto team created the
lost tapes of the 27 club a project
featuring songs written and mostly
performed by machines in the styles of
other musicians who died at age 27 jimi
hendrix jim morrison and amy winehouse
to name a few
sony has previously used the software to
make a new song from the beatles
so here's how it works
each track is the result of ai programs
analyzing up to 30 songs by each artist
and granularly studying the song section
by section that is drums guitar vocals
and more
for example if you want a new guitar
riff you just input a bunch of
guitarists from the original artist and
then the ai will produce a new one
the limitation in all of this though is
that it can't do an entire song
structure or it gets confused
so digging deeper rather than the
artist's songs being fed in and
processed as raw audio they're first
converted into midi files
so midi files are basically bits of code
with information that tells the computer
exactly how to play a digital instrument
that is the volume the length of the
note or a particular beat or rhythm etc
here's an example of midi for those who
aren't aware
so you can see these lines that are
drawn and that's the digital information
of the note you can hear how it sounds
but see i can change the sound of the
note at will but the midi information of
what note it's playing and the length of
these notes will stay consistent
so the ai works with this digital midi
information
[Music]
after examining each artist's note
choices rhythm process and preferences
for harmony in midi format the ai
creates new music in the form of midi
files
at this stage it's really a jumble of
notes and it's up to humans to sift
through and pick out the best moments
by using artists previous lyrics it
tries to come up with new lyrics in the
artist style but once again these have
to be sifted through by humans to make
sense
once the raw midi files and lyrics were
in place they were performed by cover
artists for example eric hogan performed
as kurt cobain
[Music]
the google team also created ableton
plugins and i think this is really cool
in this example it can listen to a
baseline and automatically generate a
drum pattern to go with it imagine
you're a producer
you're starting a new song and you have
a bass line that you like a lot but you
know you maybe either don't have access
to a drum kit or you're not a talented
or skillful drummer yourself you can use
the uh drumify plug-in to take that
baseline and and create a an
accompanying drumbeat to kind of
continue your compositional process so
let's just hear a quick example of this
in practice so first you're going to
hear a bass line
that somebody made
[Music]
so now we're going to take that and
we're going to turn it into a drum beat
to accompany
with phi
[Music]
so that was just using the the bass line
the onsets of the bass notes extracting
that rhythm and then with this with just
a few clicks you can create a drum beat
to go along with that so that's just one
example of the types of things we're
working on
okay so now let's take a look at a
different method by open ai and i think
this one is pretty cool
so open ai has taken a different
approach instead of doing midi files it
uses raw audio to train a model and the
model spits out raw audio in return
voices and all
i think this method for ai music
creation is much more interesting
the models were trained on a raw data
set of 1.2 million songs and used
metadata and lyrics from lyric wiki
the program works in two main ways
specify a genre and this will make
something from scratch or feed it a
section of a song and let it continue
writing that song here are some
interesting examples
[Music]
really
[Applause]
but this second sample is interesting
because for one thing i fed it a metal
tune and it completely changed up the
feel when it took over
[Applause]
[Music]
i had it generate three different songs
and then i took the best parts and kind
of mashed them together to make an ai
remix so here's that
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
go
[Music]
so this is a little bit cursed but also
it generated some genuinely really cool
stuff i love the kind of push and pull
of the groove
it is really interesting isn't it
i also find it entertaining to listen to
the unpredictability that comes out from
time to time there are limitations
though the further the ai gets away from
the initial point of the song the more
the direction becomes unstable if this
happens the song eventually becomes
unlistenable
i remember that i'd always have
arguments with my good friend who was
studying computer science six or seven
years ago we argued about music
specifically and if it could ever be
created by an ai i was adamant that they
just can't manage the creative process
like humans can he on the other hand
thought it was only a matter of time
before it happened but i do admit we
seem to be closer now than we ever were
before it was a fascinating debate and
something that was worth discussing
so this leads us to the big question
what is creativity is it the expression
of the soul or is it just a set of rules
that we don't yet understand let's dig
into this a bit more
the oxford dictionary defines creativity
as quote the use of skill and
imagination to produce something new or
to produce art
so is ai creative let's break it down
as we can see creativity needs three
things
skill imagination and the production of
something new let's tackle the last part
first
in the last episode we saw that
generative adversarial networks or gans
do indeed produce new examples never
seen before so we can tick that one off
so what about imagination
well we need to define that a bit more
the oxford dictionary states that
imagination is quote the ability to
create pictures in your mind
and as we saw again in the previous
episode
gans can arguably do that so we can
probably tick that one off as well
okay so what about skill
skill is defined as the ability to do
something well
well let's see
this point is probably easier shown in
images than audio so let's take a look
at some ai being creative in images
this is open ai's dal e an ai that turns
user written text into images
here's a set of images with the input
text being an avocado chair
and another set of images with the input
text being blue pumpkin mural
it's not like there's a database of blue
pumpkin murals for it to learn from so
it is indeed creating something and it
seems like it's doing it from scratch
so by all accounts of the oxford
dictionary it seems like ai can be
creative
so what do you think about that
for me something just doesn't sit right
here
by definition machines may be creative
but there was no soul or thought process
behind it
in my view the concept of inspiration is
missing
consider an artist calmly sitting in a
cafe watching the world go by a
particular smell or taste ignites a
nostalgic memory in him or her the
feeling becomes the inspiration for a
new seed in a new musical piece
inspiration is part of the human
experience but we don't understand how
that works
it seems simple enough but it's kind of
a mystery
so i guess today with ai we're beginning
to understand the structure of
creativity but not much else in a way
teaching ai to become creative helps us
understand ourselves
but i think it really shouldn't be
forgotten just how amazing the human
mind is and just how vast and intriguing
something as simple as creativity is we
take it for granted sometimes
[Music]
we've been referencing artificial
intelligence a lot if you're curious
about that and would like to learn more
about the inner workings of ai or a
bunch of other maths and science topics
you can do that with brilliant.org
brilliant.org offers engaging and
enlightening science and maths courses i
found their ai course to be very
effective in teaching the underlying
concepts that underpin the technology
if you want to support cold fusion and
start learning visit brilliant.org
coldfusion to sign up for free
the first 200 people that go to the link
will get 20 off their annual premium
subscription so thank you
okay so let's wrap up we looked at the
human process versus the ai process of
creating music and touched on the
philosophical question of what it means
to be creative i think both the
practical applications of ai and music
production as well as the philosophical
creation is extremely fascinating
okay so i'm going to leave you with a
twitter page for ai generated art it
works by the user typing in a text
prompt and the ai will dream up
corresponding images
so thanks for watching if you're new to
this channel feel free to subscribe
my name is dagogo and you've been
watching cold fusion and i'll see you
again soon for the next video and if
you're interested in listening to the
full version of that song that i was
making as a demonstration it's already
up on my second channel cold fusion
music
cheers guys
have a good one
it's me thinking
[Music]
you